Welcome back guys I am Nate with the King of Random
We recently made a video with a gummy heart and today
We're gonna try and make one more fun
Halloween treat
Grant made these two silicone molds off of actual brains and in previous videos has made a zombie brain using green and purple versions of his
gummy candy
today We're going to try and make a new kind of zombie brain using some green and white chocolate and some watermelon flavored gummy candy
We're going to try to have a few different layers the outside layer will be green so the whole thing will look like a zombie
Brain old and molding and gross after the green layer
We'll have a white layer of chocolate and then our watermelon flavored and colored gummy candy
Hopefully that means that when we crack open our zombie brain. We'll have nice slices of candy watermelon as a fun little bonus
We've got these little licorice pieces
And we're gonna cut them up to be used as watermelon seeds
The first step is to melt our green chocolate and coat the inside of our brain molds
All right, we've got a bag of chocolate
That's been microwaved and is nice and liquid feeling so I'm just gonna cut off the corner
Squirt it into the mold and then rotate the mold around to try and get a nice even coating
So the difficulty I'm running into is that while the chocolate does get considerably more liquid than when it starts
It doesn't exactly end up running so trying to get it to flow around
Evenly inside all the crevices of the mold is a little bit tricky
Putting a little bit of chocolate right on my finger and spreading it around to a couple spots that I see some gaps
Just to try and get a little bit of coverage, I think it's actually working pretty well, though
That stuff gets you messy almost immediately, but I'm liking the color it's good for both watermelon rind and zombie brains
Our green chocolate has started to cool, so let's move on to the white chocolate
White chocolate seems to be a little runnier than the green chocolate was so yeah, it's definitely flowing better
Maybe all that green dye kind of solidifies it or something. I don't know
The heat from the white chocolate. I think has melted a little bit of the green chocolate with it
You can see it's got some green in it as it pours out
I think that means it'll just be bonded together really well
Yeah
That looks really a lot better coated this time than it did the first time so I don't think I have to go and spread
Any in there, I think it's nice and evenly done
Alright now for the next one
This isn't as entertaining as I'm making it look
Unless you really like shaking chocolate in this case
This is more entertaining than I'm making it look
Pour out the extra same thing little bits of green coming out with it heat from the white chocolate melted some of the green chocolate
That's good there
You have it the
green chocolate and the white chocolate are both poured into the molds and separate layers now
We just have to let those cool down a little bit before we add our gummy mixture
And it's just got swirls of green and white chocolate
I'll take these two molds and pop them in the freezer for about 10 minutes
Which is about how long it takes to make our gummy mixture?
Our chocolate in the mold is cooling off in the freezer and while it is. Let's start mixing up our gummy mixture
We'll start with two cups of cold water and one cup of corn syrup
Stir the corn syrup until it's evenly dissolved into the water with our corn syrup
Evenly mixed in will add eight packets of gelatin and four boxes of jell-o
Now our gelatin is mixed in let's throw our pot on the stove
We'll let this heat up for about 10 minutes stirring it every minute or two
Our gummy mixture has started to cool down just a little bit
So I'm going to pull the bubbles off of the surface of it, so we have a nice clean cast
Let's grab the brain molds out of the freezer and start pouring in our gummy mixture
What I'm going to try and do is pour our gummy mixture into the molds
Let it cool down for a minute and then pour it back out
I'm hoping this will help form a layer of the gummy mix on the inside of the chocolate
Then I'm going to use our black licorice seeds mix that into the rest of the gummy mixture and pour it back in my goal
Is for the black licorice seeds to stay evenly suspended in the gummy mixture and not just all fall to the bottom
Now we just gotta wait for a few minutes
Our molds have had a few minutes to cool down and hopefully form a nice layer of gummy candy on the inside of the chocolate
I'm going to pour out what's left of the gummy candy, mix in our watermelon seeds and pour it back in
Got a little bit of chocolate going out with that
I hope it hasn't melted our chocolate layer too much after all this is an experiment
I haven't done it before it doesn't look like it's formed much of a layer in there
So it might have been too warm when I poured it in
We'll see. I'm gonna give it just a little bit more time to cool down and thicken up
Hopefully our watermelon seeds will stay suspended in the middle of it
For at least in the pot
It looks kind of like watermelon so that's something
It seemed like it was cooling off a little unevenly so I think parts of it are kind of lumpy now
I'm not sure how well this is going to go into the mold
It's working it's going in
Kind of
Go in, go in
Alright this I started to set a little bit too much
So I'm just gonna throw it on the stove on really low heat to get it a little bit softer and then pour it back in
Trying to get it at just the right stage so that things stay suspended in the middle of it
But you can still pour it is pretty tricky
I'm trying to keep this stirring around as it cools off a little bit, so it won't get so clumpy like it did before
All right, I've been stirring this as it cools down and you can see it's turned very gelatinous
And the seeds are now
Suspended in it so before it cools down so much that it can't pour I'm gonna try and fill the molds
Man it's cooling really fast come on fill fill fill the mold
Okay that got pretty messy in there as you can see it's sticking to my hands. It's sticking to the mold
it's really tough to get a consistency that both suspends the watermelon seed pieces and
Can still pour into the mold and it goes from one to the other in just a matter of seconds
I do think I got most of the mold full and I also have a hope that all of the mixing around
Added some bubbles into it which will give it sort of more of the look and texture of the inside of watermelon
So here's hoping that worked in our favor now
We just need to let these cool for a while then we can take them out of the mold and check our result
Our zombie brains have now had a chance to cool down completely so it's time to de-mold them and see how they turned out
It's starting to peel this away
Brain molds are surprisingly complicated like there's a lot of different ins and outs of them
So I don't want it to grip too much onto the candy
Think everything else that we've molded in this brain mold was actually like flexible and gummy
So this might be the most rigid piece that we've ever tried to take out of it. It's a little tricky
We're gonna have a couple small bits of silicone
left over stuck in the cracks, but that
That is one gross looking zombie brain
On and then we got like the watermelon colored brain stem coming out over here
Brainy. okay, let's try and get our second brain out too
ooh. Chocolate is cracking on this one
Few IQ points down every time something breaks off
Zombie might not be very bright. Yeah, that's really sticking to the silicone in places apparently I should not be a brain surgeon I
Think his insurance is gonna cover this
Well there's part of it
Yeah, this is like after the zombie got hit in the head with a shotgun or something
I Don't know the apocalypse was not kind to this one there you have it
There's our two separate brains the first one came out pretty well
You can see some of the gummy down at the bottom the second one for some reason
The gummy wasn't stuck very well to the chocolate and the chocolate was stuck really well to the silicone
So it kind of broke into more pieces when it came out
I still have one main largest piece, but a lot of the exterior brain didn't survive the operation
Well this brain is already cracked so I say let's cut it down in half and see if we've got that
watermelon look we were hoping for
There you go, there is our watermelon chocolate brain
Someplace this is weird like it's oh my gosh the whole thing. I think you're just gonna slide right out
That's gross that kind of reminds me of a hermit crab coming out of its shell
Look at this letting it cool off for a while might have messed with it pouring, but like you can see the seeds
Suspended in the watermelon gummy, and that worked pretty well
And I said that I hope that the air would actually make it look more like watermelon. I think that worked too
there it is oh
man and somehow we got
Green, then white then green again. I don't know how that happened. I'm trying to go pretty slow
Cause I don't want to crack the chocolate
Well I cracked a little bit on that side and on that side, let's just cut down through see what we get
Well there we go look at that
That is beautiful look at that watermelon look
Got the green. You got the white you got the fruit and you got the seeds all suspended in there. I turned out wonderful
There we go two candy zombie brains that are watermelon on the inside
We've got layers of green and white then watermelon with seeds in it
I think this turned out pretty great if you want you can just take the whole green brains put them on display
And make a great Halloween decoration then when it's time to eat you can crack them open. You've got white chocolate
You've got the watermelon if you like black licorice
You can eat the seeds as well this has been a great project
And I'm really happy with the result we got thanks for joining us for this video
And I look forward to the next one talk to you then
That just shatters right off, and then you just have like smooshed zombie brains
brains
Here's our brain
Now it's a watermelon brain
Watermelon and white chocolate not bad also zombie brains not bad